a fraction of a second ago the
electricity powering your lights your
air conditioning your television your
refrigerator nearly everything electric
around you right now was water gas wind
or some other form of energy potentially
hundreds or thousands of miles away
if you flip a light switch in los
angeles that could cause a turbine in
washington to start spinning
electric grids are considered some of
the single largest machines in existence
they stretch across entire continents
but they're machines with absolutely
zero slack with water systems for
example there's some extra supply in a
storage reservoir at the treatment plant
and some extra supply in the pipes
connecting the treatment plant to your
home supply only has to roughly match
demand but that's not the case with
electricity
your lights your tv your microwave
everything plugged into the grid uses
electricity produced just moments ago
for the sake of example let's look at
what it takes to turn on the lights at
the public library in the small town of
glenwood springs colorado
now what makes the relatively
straightforward task of converting
natural fuels or phenomena into electric
power difficult is the huge variability
in demand from minute to minute and
month to month
there are however some trends on an
annual basis the peaks correlate to
climate january represents the winter
high water mark as many homes and
businesses turn on their electric
heating while july typically ranks
highest outright as the country battles
summer heat with air conditioners the
month to month variations are not that
significant though the difference
between the highest and lowest demand
months is less than a third most of the
variability happens across a given day
in january all regions of the u.s
observe a two-peak daily demand trend
where electricity use spikes around 7am
as people turn up their thermostats and
fire up lights and appliances as they
wake up and get ready for the day
then demand peaks again when people
return from work in the evening and do
the same meanwhile in july energy use is
highest in the late afternoon or early
evening but this does depend on the
region for example in the sweltering
southwest usage peaks around 4 pm around
the hottest hour of the afternoon when
air conditioners have to work the
hardest in the more temperate northwest
though which includes colorado and that
glenwood springs public library fewer
buildings have air conditioning so
demand peaks around 6 pm pulled back by
post-work use of appliances lights
televisions and more these trends then
get further complicated by holidays and
special events for example on super bowl
sunday in the us demand plummets for a
few hours as people turn off the lights
stop cooking and gather together at
others homes to watch the big game this
is all to say when forecasting demand
utilities need to factor in the hour day
season location and plenty more
now with whatever demand materializes
utilities then need to essentially
instantly match supply
to do this they layer different energy
sources on top of each other often the
lowest layer is nuclear power nuclear
power stations aren't designed to be
able to turn off and on easily it would
take the better part of a day to shut
down and start up again so it's rather
impractical to operate these in response
to demand in addition considering how
massively expensive their construction
is it would be economically inefficient
to let these stations run idle therefore
they'll run nearly continuously for the
entirety of their service lives except
for during planned maintenance this
means they provide the most stable
supply of electricity 24 7. colorado no
longer operates any nuclear power plants
but does have six of the next layer coal
power stations like nuclear most of
these coal plants cannot be fired up
quickly as they take some time to get up
to temperature so utilities will also
run them essentially continuously coal
and nuclear combined typically fulfill
what's called the base load their
continuous production essentially equals
the valley of demand they'll make the
minimum amount of power needed at a
point in the day so then on top of that
utilities need production methods that
can fire up and shut down far faster
they need to be able to produce the
power to operate all those ac units in
hot summer afternoons the bulk of this
job is completed by natural gas-fired
plants of the 25 in colorado 13 of these
stations generate using a simple cycle
combustion turbine this is the simplest
means of turning natural gas into
electricity much like a jet engine the
fuel is used to turn a turbine which
turns a generator which produces
electricity more advanced natural gas
power plants recover the hot exhaust to
convert it into electricity too but the
startup process for these takes longer
so simple cycle stations are used for
applications where speed is key
most can reach full power within 15
minutes making them an effective tool to
respond to those short peaks and demands
nuclear coal and natural gas are some of
the more traditional means of generating
electricity the recent proliferation of
renewable energy sources though has
kick-started a reinvention of the system
of baseload and peaker plants that's
because when wind and solar generating
stations can make power that power is
essentially free meaning there's
essentially no additional variable cost
to generate power once the panels or
turbines are installed that's not the
case with natural gas-fired plants for
example as the gas itself represents one
of their primary costs so this
essentially creates a new bottom layer
to the energy mix but it's a bottom
layer that's uncontrollably variable one
sunny windy day could mean that a state
has an excess of electricity when added
to its base load sources well one cloudy
windless day could mean that the peaker
plants have to operate at full force
solar and onshore wind power are now
some of the cheapest sources of
electricity but because they rely on
natural phenomena they can't match
supply to demand the way that the
traditional nuclear coal natural gas
trifecta can therefore grids are being
reinvented so that supply doesn't have
to match demands at least minute to
minutes of course the way to do that is
with storage but storing electricity is
not easy the average american household
uses about 30 kilowatt hours of
electricity per day lithium-ion
batteries currently cost around 130
dollars per kilowatt hour meaning
one-day storage for one household would
cost around 3 900 in batteries and
that's excluding all the additional
infrastructure needed to make such an
installation possible considering the
average american household pays less
than half of that per year in
electricity bills installing such a
system grid wide would be economically
impractical nonetheless colorado has
four battery electric storage systems
albeit at a relatively minor scale the
largest of which is used to power fort
carson a us army base near colorado
springs they charge up the 8.5 megawatt
battery at night when electricity demand
and therefore rates are low then use the
power during the day when the majority
of the base's electricity use occurs the
system savings should make up for its
installation costs in about 13 years
then by the end of its practical
lifespan it's expected to have saved the
army about half a million dollars in
electricity costs
while such a system can make economic
sense for large complexes that can
invest in infrastructure that won't pay
off for more than a decade it's just not
practical grid-wide at least right now
even if there was the battery production
capacity to make a meaningful dent in
the world's electricity use the savings
just happen too far in the future for
most to consider such storage to be
worth it however for entirely different
reasons in the coming decades more and
more people will be purchasing massive
battery packs the ones inside their evs
with most forecasts suggesting that some
third of new car sales in the us will be
electric by 2030 a potential solution to
the grid storage need could arise
naturally a rivian r1t for example holds
a 135 kilowatt hour battery pack meaning
it could theoretically power the average
american household for four and a half
days while evs typically take in
electricity little stands in the way
technologically from them giving that
electricity back to the grid so the idea
is that evs could charge at night or
when renewables are performing well then
supply some of that electricity back to
the grid during the day while parked and
plugged in in exchange vehicle owners
would be compensated a small amount by
the utility company while the real world
wide scale economics have yet to be
proven especially in the face of battery
degradation this vehicle to grid concept
could potentially play a cooperative
role in the transition towards a greener
grid
now the largest current battery electric
storage system in colorado the fort
carson installation has 8.5 megawatts of
capacity elsewhere in the state however
there is a massive different form of
battery that can power over ten thousand
homes at once
and it looks like this
water is one of the earliest forms of
energy that humans harnessed and it
still represents one of the best sources
of electricity hydroelectric power is
the best of both worlds while there's
certainly the potential for
environmental damage from damming up
rivers the carbon impact is near zero
meaning hydro is green like wind and
solar however it's also reliable in
theory hydroelectric dams can start and
stop making power in minutes even if in
practice a minimum flow is typically
maintained so they can operate like
those natural gas single cycle peaker
plants responding to demand
of course there's only so much water
upstream especially in a place like
colorado which is in the midst of a 20
year long drought but hydroelectric dams
simply convert potential energy into
electric energy there's no reason why
that process can't happen in reverse
that's what happens here at the cabin
creek generating station when
electricity is cheap typically at night
or when wind and solar are performing at
their peak the facility uses it to pump
water to its upper higher elevation
reservoir then when electricity is
expensive and in demand like in the late
afternoon it will start flowing that
water through its turbines out into its
lower reservoir it's essentially a form
of price arbitrage but it's one that's
already helping smooth out the peaks and
valleys of wind and solar power
production
now no matter how well supply is matched
to demand electricity is of no use to
that glenwood springs colorado library
until of course it gets there many have
an image of power plants as something
sitting just outside every town and city
well that's how the earliest grids
operated it's hardly the case anymore
despite dramatic declines in the past
decade some 42 percent of colorado's
power supply still comes from coal
that means that nearly half of the
state's electricity originates from
essentially just six sites this dates
coal power stations therefore the
ability to effectively transport
electricity over a long distance is
essential
now what makes long distance
transmission tricky is simple the
further you send electricity the more
you lose along the way typically through
unavoidable conversion to heat
meanwhile the more centralized your
electricity production the less it costs
it's simple economies of scale therefore
the task of transmission is all about
balancing these competing effects to
find an equilibrium
now houses businesses and other
buildings connected to the grid all use
alternating current power a big reason
why this standard beat out its direct
current competitor in the days of tesla
westinghouse and edison is because it's
relatively easy to convert ac power
between higher and lower voltages using
transformers what makes this crucial is
that the higher the voltage the less
electricity lost during transmission
specifically a doubling in voltage
quarters the power loss in transmission
that relatively simple voltage
transformation allows for a more
efficient electricity distribution
system
colorado's second largest power plant is
this the crag generating station it
connects to some of the state's highest
voltage transmission lines two of which
head due south until the town of rifle
now these lines operate at 345 kilovolts
which means that in theory over the 75
mile or 120 kilometer stretch from craig
to rifle about 3.2 percent of the
electricity is lost a relatively minor
amount thanks to the efficiency of high
voltage transmission
other more densely populated regions
which need more electric transmission
capacity have even higher voltage lines
all the way up to 765 kilovolts the
current highest voltage transmission
standard in the us
quite few of these lines exist in the us
there's one connecting quebec to new
york state and then a larger system
spanning between illinois and virginia
these can carry about six times as much
electricity as the 345 kilovolt line
between craig and rifle and thanks to
their high voltage see as little as 0.6
loss per 100 miles or 160 kilometers
that means that in theory assuming the
infrastructure existed a 765 kilowatt
line could transmit electricity from new
york to la and about 87 percent of it
would still be there at the other end
that's why these high voltage lines are
becoming more and more common
but what's even more efficient than
transmitting an alternating current at a
super high voltage is transmitting a
direct current of course the difficulty
with direct current is that transforming
it between voltages is more expensive
than with ac and for use in today's grid
it has to be converted to ac power which
is also expensive however compared to
the absolute lowest 0.6 loss per 100
miles with the highest voltage ac lines
dc lines see as little as 0.45 percent
loss per 100 miles therefore when
there's a need to transmit a huge amount
of electricity over a long distance the
economics can work in favor of
converting power to dc at its origin and
converting it back to ac at its
destination perhaps the most prominent
application of such a system in the us
is the pacific dc intertie stretching
between northern oregon and los angeles
california in the summer the temperate
northwest has relatively little power
demand but generates a huge amount of
cheap electricity thanks to a tiger
electric dams
so the pacific dc intertie sends this
electricity south to power los angeles
air conditioners during its hot summer
meanwhile in the winter los angeles sees
temperate weather and little need for
climate control so it sends its excess
electricity north to the pacific
northwest to power its electric heating
phenomena like this demonstrates why
creating a greener more efficient grid
involves a proliferation of
long-distance power transmission
infrastructure it's needed to balance
out seasonal trends and to bring power
from where it can be produced easily to
where it cannot
back in colorado though its relatively
minor 345 kilowatt line from the craig
power station eventually enters this
more populated area flinking interstate
70.
here there are a number of nearby towns
that need electricity but sending 345
kilovolts to each of these would not be
efficient that's simply because the
higher the voltage the higher the
construction cost a 345 kilovolt
substation might cost 10.7 million
dollars while 235 kilowatt one just 7.6
meanwhile a 345 kilovolt line costs
around 4.5 million dollars per mile to
build while a 230 kilovolt line just 2.8
million
therefore even though the transmission
losses will be greater a number of
substations around rifle transform the
electricity to 230 kilovolts and then
smaller cheaper lines carry the flow
west south and east closer to its final
customers about 30 miles or 50
kilometers to the east this line
encounters another substation which
steps it down to just 69 kilovolts and
then another yet smaller line circles
back towards glenwood springs the powers
then step down again to 12.47 kilovolts
before a final transformer converts it
to 120 240 or 480 volts the voltage is
used by almost all buildings in the us
including the public library of glenwood
springs colorado
unlike with electricity the supply of
domain names is stable there's only one
wendoverproductions.com for example even
as demand grows and grows there are now
more websites on the internet than ever
before around 2 billion so if there's
even a chance you will want to make one
in the future
now is the time to buy your domain
before it's gone our sponsor hover makes
that incredibly easy whether you want
the domain corresponding to your name
your business your youtube channel or
anything else hover makes finding it
super simple and you can even get extra
creative and stand out with your over
400 domain extensions like i did with
our wendover.productions domain plus
with your new custom domain hover can
set up a custom email address in seconds
meaning you can stand out with a first
name at lastname.com email address for
example hover also has super fair
transparent pricing and truly awesome
customer support making them
definitively the best place to go to get
your domain there's a reason why i've
bought every domain of mine through
hover and you can too for 10 off by
clicking the button on screen or heading
to hover.comwendover
and you'll be helping support the
channel while you're at it